thank you joining me now is harmy Dillon
founder of the Dillon Law Group a firm
doing some legal work uh for former
president Trump also with me Victor
Davis Hansen senior fellow at the Hoover
institution two great people to hear
from tonight uh harmeet your reaction to
some of this information that's coming
out you know gag orders mug shots 34
felony counts but it also stepping back
and I'll Victor I'll ask you about this
as well the spectacle that was today a
president of the United States
submitting to an indictment uh and what
will happen tomorrow
well this is unprecedented of course and
when you look at all the aspects of this
that are unprecedented I actually
disagree with Saul about whether the
former president can get a fair trial
here because remember how this district
attorney actually came to office uh
almost unprecedented in American history
he actually campaigned on the idea that
if elected he would make it his top
priority to concoct some kind of a case
against the former president that is a
very troubling Crossing of a line that I
think you're going to see repeated all
over the country now in retaliation for
this clearly politicized prosecution the
latest that I'm hearing from the folks
who've been in the mix there in New York
today includes that there may not be a
gag order and you know as we talk about
New York law it actually looks at also
whether a gag order would even be
effective at this point here again
there's been a campaign about this
potential prosecution it's been talked
about in the Press it's been leaked to
the Press clearly and so the the judge
may take the view that the publicity has
already been had and a Curative of
restriction on media isn't going to have
the effect necessary plus all the
negative aspects of that but what I want
to say finally about this is that we'll
go through this process and if the judge
is being fair I think this case should
be dismissed but if it isn't then you
know there are a number of I think
defects with what we're hearing about
this case and
setting that aside what has been opened
here as a Pandora's box of politicized
prosecutions being touted and being had
in this country and that's incredibly
disturbing for confidence in the rule of
law
no doubt Victor we've all pointed out
the fact that this is unprecedented but
set the scene of what this says about
the state of our Republic uh and what it
says about just us as a country
well it means elections and politics are
going to be settled by other means and
that's law fair what this does now is
it's going to unleash every wannabe
local or state prosecutor who wants to
be a celebrity or has a political ax to
grind or is in service for the national
party to go after ex-presence or anybody
and I mean it's going to be a red blue
State divide any any type of business
that Hunter Biden or Joe Biden conducted
that may be questionable in a red State
a local prosecutor could do this to
embarrass the president and when he
comes out of office there's going to be
a lot of people go after him and is this
the type of tit for tout we want we got
to remember that they're they're
destroying block by block the foundation
of this country the Constitutional
Foundation Mr Trump was the first
president to be impeached twice we know
now from his call and subsequent
information about the Biden family
consindicate they had there was
legitimate concern about their
relationship with Ukraine and Hunter
Biden's activity he was the first
president to be tried as a private
citizen when he was out of office he was
the first president to have his home
residence raided after he was out of
office and now he's the first president
to be brought up on these charges which
most legal experts believe are
Superfluous but more importantly this is
if you put it in a longer context I mean
this is not FDR having sexual relations
with Lucy Mercer in the white house it's
not Bill Clinton and Monica Lewinsky in
the white house it's not JFK and Mimi
Alford in the White House this is 16
years ago and with some private matter
that may or may not have taken place and
was was dragged up to continue this
process and when you look back at all of
these incidents Pete there was no
Russian collusion the hunter laptop
Biden was not Russian disinformation
that was used to affect an election on
its Eve there was the the Mar-A-Lago
raid was not a unique instance of a
president taking out classified
documents because Joe Biden without the
authority to declassify them put them in
three at least three residents with much
less security so in each one of these
cases in retrospect and post facto there
was no there there and so what are we
doing we're just trying to say that
Donald Trump is Crow a course or he's
extraordinarily different or he's not
part of the establishment and we're
going to destroy him and what it's going
to pose an existential question to the
Republicans what do they do they're the
adult in the room do they have to reply
apply Tit for Tat do they have to tear
up the State of the Union Address on
national TV do they have to deny
minority representation on committees do
they have to always threaten to get rid
of the filibuster to bring in two new
states is that what they is that what we
come to to destroy the Republic just for
them
it's really scary
it's scary it is really scary that's and
that's incredibly important historical
context as we talk about what might
happen tomorrow it really is tectonic
plates shifting under our Republic uh
great perspective from you both Victor
Harvey thank you so much tonight thank
you hey Sean Hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to Fox News YouTube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere else